foreign
podcast katori Walker is here ladies and
gentlemen Pasadena's finest Pasadena's
fine as well that's a big title
from Pasadena uh like I said hey hey guy
ties to Pasadena I don't know if he was
born there but I know his family's from
there uh who else is in Pasadena there's
a lot of up-and-coming artists in
Pasadena do y'all know uh you know
overdose of course yeah so yeah I didn't
know they were from Pasadena yeah yeah
so what happened to those guys I don't
know I know Ken Jam is still doing this
thing I interviewed them and they were
hilarious those guys were hilarious
shout out to overdose
um but welcome man you're having a
pretty crazy year
um your project Idols would you say that
as a body of work this has been the your
biggest body of work as far as like
recognition
yeah performance because you had like
like were you ranking this one at I
would say this is my most free body of
work and this is my most like honest
body at work this is the one like the
ones that I'm most proud of you know
like you know every other body of work
has done different things for me but
this one is just like yo all right this
dude can really do his damn thing you
know yeah for people who are listening
who might not have heard of you uh you
put a record out called idols and uh um
the the concept of the album was really
to pay homage to
your Idols in the music industry it's an
EP each record is dedicated to
uh we got what Kendra Cole Drake Kanye
50 50. yeah and then one to yourself one
to myself yeah yeah
um when you were making like like was
was the idea a conscious idea when you
were recording it or did you like hear
the songs be like you know what this
this was like like like or did you do it
on was everything on purpose
um I think half of the project was on
purpose I think I did I did one song and
I was actually trying to mimic code like
yeah I want to do a code flow on this
one and that was a record that I didn't
even make the project actually because I
had two Code records so and I'm like yo
this this is dope and then I did a
Kendrick record I'm like oh this is dope
you know and then after that I was just
like yo I'm gonna put this all together
and make this a body of work you know
and like the last ones I did was the
fallback record for myself and then the
higher hopes of Kanye one because I was
like the toughest thing to do because
Kanye is like a Swiss army knife so how
do you oh yeah yeah Kanye's he's my
favorite artist yeah he's the artist for
real bro yeah I'm more than a fan of
Jesus's King I'm not gonna lie but you
know discography wise nobody can [__]
with you yeah I think I think the thing
that I got from Jesus is King is I felt
that piece listening to it it wasn't the
best lyric album it wasn't the best mix
album at all but it felt peaceful it was
great production for me there was some
great production on there shout out to
bugs the beast but um but yeah it's dope
because like
not a lot of people pay homage to 50 as
much as they should 50 is a pioneer
bro 50 is like his run was so it was it
was I mean it's right at the top was
short right it was two albums long plus
the G-Unit album and then you know the
Curtis came out and things kind of went
left but
you know we're talking get rich or die
trying is like I feel like
unarguably a top five album of all time
yeah you could put a higher but I feel
like if you put it any lower than five
you're [__] lying yeah or you're a
hater but like definitely dope like to
see someone pay homage to 50 because I
don't feel like that happens a lot of
people pay homage this year like a lot
of people I think it was what three or
four minimum oh yeah yeah that was a lot
you know you're right it's a good year
for 50 because 21 Savage did it pop pop
smoke did it yeah and I did it yeah I
don't know who else did it but yeah so
it was all that same record and that was
all get rich or die trying so yeah he's
getting the respect he deserved like 50
had a video game bro like not a lot of
rappers who say like hey and it wasn't a
bad game it was a great game that [__]
was solid you'd be with young buck Lloyd
Banks spraying up fools in Iraq like
what the [__] is going on
50 50 had a crazy run that was the first
time I was listening to 50 when I was I
think I think that was what 2002 when
that came out 2001 to 20032 I think
you're right 202 2003 bro yeah that was
when I first started writing my own raps
because when I was young I used to have
like my uncles right myself for me so I
was listening to get rich or die trying
China pin out some [__] like to mimic 50
so that's why that album meant the world
to me and the unit album was fire beg
for mercy was crazy that was a great
album 50 was like I don't think he got
enough credit for his hooks bro oh my
God that's why when they were talking
about like the game in 50 verses I was
like
like game is a legend I love game love
his music but like his biggest songs
that he could play have 50 Cent on them
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah and
it's like how would that work yeah they
both wrap it together yeah it's a point
for each it's like a point for each yeah
but you're not um and then the artwork
what was dope about your artwork for
your project was it just kind of
Incorporated all of that on like in a
very tasteful way
um
What whose idea was was the artwork so
me and my uh creative manager his name
is Cass we had just been trying to
figure out how to match everybody's like
face together and just looked it weird
so then I'm like yo let's take a piece
of each every each album that we like
the most from every artist and make it a
thing and then we just was like okay
cool we're gonna take the border from
Kendrick we're gonna take the heart from
Kanye we're gonna take the sky from
Dragon take the crown from coal and
we're like what the [__] are we gonna do
for 50. I I was like yo let's just sit
on it he hit me back an hour later like
check your text I'm like I seen the
bullet holes I'm like my God it's done
it's done out of here I was sending
people that I'm covered before it even
came out like yo just look you don't
even hate you don't even need to hear it
just look at the album cover bro
um when I when me and had linked up with
you it was like almost two years ago
um you had you were coming into a
situation with capital
um what's the update or the status of
your situation record label wise we cut
ties I'm now independent I um you know
Capital we had our run right no we did
our thing and I think for where I wanted
to go and what I'm trying to do we just
wasn't seeing eye to eye and then you
know Lord rested so my a r ended up
passing away so it was like that was
just a thing you know so
um
I'm now independent I want to be able to
like freely move you know do what you
want to do yeah man I don't think you
know unless it's a bag player I don't
think label's got that much power these
days you ain't lying yeah I mean look
bro I was it's crazy because you got
you're on the playlist that you that the
label would get you on anyway yeah yeah
man I got on the playlist just off the
strength when I first dropped I wasn't
on no playlist and I think
Carl Cherry had heard and was like yo
it's crazy yeah I saw him like tweeting
like tweeting out your lyrics and [__]
yeah and it's like yo bro I don't know
you from nowhere yeah so that was just
an organic thing it was just organic bro
because you know he's like the gate the
gatekeeper that everyone yeah it was
organic bro and he had hit me like bro
this is crazy this is crazy and I'm like
yo I'm glad you tapping in with the
music and speaking of the label this is
something that the label had had for a
year
you know it's also kind of like
reaffirms the fact that you don't need
the label because really what else like
that's why that's what they're there for
right is to try to get you placements or
you know but dog if you are like outside
of a bag like you said yeah what else
what else do you need a label for these
days like you gonna give somebody 20 of
what you're doing the Press upload I
want to ask you so we're going to go
through the project and I want you to
tell me your favorite albums from each
of these artists well obviously it's got
to be give it your dad trying for 50. oh
yeah of course that goes what I'm saying
by the way Massacre super slept on yeah
um but what about I mean you say your
favorite is it was 808 your favorite
album since you use the heart nah that
[__] just was assembled it makes sense
uh graduation graduation situation it's
like bro that was impeccable it's a
great body of work it's like
I don't know like I think everybody
likes to say My Beautiful Dark Twisted
but that that I'm a late registration
guy oh also older older Kanye yeah I
love late registration yeah graduation
was solid and I just
I don't know man I'm like I'm like I'm
not as high as graduation on on
graduation as everyone else why not it's
a great app look Kanye's got the best
discography ever yeah
he's got a great discography I feel like
uh late registration and College Dropout
were like brother sister albums it kind
of sounded I didn't hear that much
evolution in the in the body of work
they kind of sound very the same nah
late registration had John Bryant on the
production it was so much I feel like
they could they could be a deluxe album
of it of each other I disagree
um all right so let's say the jump from
late registration to graduation those
are two completely things different
things late registration I feel like the
jump from each album is very different I
don't know I feel like those two are in
the same ballpark I Feel Like My
Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy is his
best album because you really can't say
[__] and then it's really up to you to
say what your favorite is yeah
yeah they're too closest they sound
sonically closest they're the they're
the closest out of any two yeah yeah
graduation yeah yeah I don't know I just
got into an argument with somebody and
YouTube was killing me because I said I
like Jesus more than graduation I um
very unpopular opinion in hip-hop I love
Jesus no no Jesus is King he go
somewhere else with that yeah yeah
he was slept on though yeah he was a
good album because I feel like nobody
really talked about mental health that
song Ghost Town yeah yeah it's hard to
make a better song than ghost town man
that song was crazy wouldn't leave was a
great record too yeah for sure for sure
for sure yeah yeah we slept and then
kids see ghosts was like yeah I feel
like kitty ghost was
sleeper for like one of the best Kanye
projects ever yeah I've never really I
know no lie no cap I've never really
been a cuddy fan like that it's crazy
I've never really been a cuddy fan no I
mean that's fair because I'm I'm uh
I wouldn't say I'm the biggest Cuddy fan
either I like doses of Cuddy
it's it's it's it's like sit through a
whole project to cut he's probably
harder for me yeah like my favorite
Cuddy project is when he was like still
like really rapping like he had a
project called a kid named Cuddy
a mixtape sponsored by 10 Deep
um and then you know the man on the moon
[__] is cool people love it um
like you can't tell [__] to a Kid Cudi
fan
because they'll be like he's the
greatest ever yeah I mean
those kind of people right yeah bro I
mean yeah those Kid Cudi fans are
[__] crazy but I get it like listen
man this music is a beautiful subjective
thing and I love Cuddy like you know in
doses I just you know I feel you on that
yeah he got his he got his Niche
audience for sure sit where he sits but
I got my my taste and my flavors uh okay
what about uh J Cole's what's your
favorite cool project all right so my
favorite cold project is definitely born
Center okay that's a great body of work
if not if not born centered in 2014 but
those are really you know Forest Hills
Drive is kind of like the consensus yeah
but that's what foreign
[Music]
Center came out the same day as Jesus
bro but I but I think don't get enough
credit is those truly yours EPS that he
put out yeah my God those body those
little projects was crazy I think uh
for just like uh nostalgic purposes I
really enjoy I still like love Friday
Night Lights
Friday Night Lights is crazy it was
that's I don't know I feel like he was
just some super duper duper right and
the warm-up was crazy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know what's crazy is like
it was cool like
he bounced back I was not a fan of his
first album because there was so much
old [__] on there so much leaked [__]
and you know what he did on that first
album we were just talking about he was
like purposely trying to make radio
records yeah the disease because you
remember like he couldn't get an album
out like they kept throwing his [__] out
and then like you know there was like Mr
Nice watch and work out and all that
[__] it was cool but like you said I
think Borden Center was like the first
time he just did what the [__] he wanted
yeah I think where he met the enough
some some [__] for the critics and [__]
for the crowd I think that's where he
finally
okay this is a hard one Kendrick because
I mean he's three for three if we're
talking major releases obviously if you
throw section 80 in there he's four for
four but like
I mean Kendrick's got no misses on his
uh yeah Kendrick is hard I think I'm
gonna say good kid Mad City because I
felt like he literally was telling my
story bar for bar like I'm talking about
like
hitting a house and [__] like that and
Friends getting murdered and all like
literally word for word bar for bar I
was like I was I was hurt like Yo God
why are you letting somebody else tell
my story like this man is telling my
story so that that resonated me with me
differently and then I liked uh
to pimp a butterfly because sonically
there it sounds like nothing I've ever
heard yeah if you put a gun in my head I
would say good bad City but to pimp a
butterflies right there too yeah and
also to pimp a butterfly was like
it's aged so well yeah when it came out
it was just I feel like it was over
everyone's head yeah nobody could handle
that I don't think we were ready for
that after after sex I'm not not Section
8 at the uh it was like yo
I had to listen to it a couple times and
as I listened to it I'm like wow and
then damn is just a [__] you know
just press play it's hit hit after three
and after yeah bro [__] all right last
one Drake
oh that's a tough one I would say as far
as albums is either gonna be take care
probably take care take care I want to
say
uh so far gone because that project did
a lot for me when I first heard it I was
like yo this is out of here but uh I say
take care if y'all listen to take care
bro that's hit after hit I appreciate it
I hate when the hip-hop has say Drake
don't have a classic album it's like
yeah bro damn
that's me I say take care is the closest
thing he has you know it's hard to take
care not a classic album well I'm not
even saying it's not a classic album
because it might be a classic to me and
to you but I just don't feel like it's
like a consensus classic like you know
how like you say like good kid Mad City
it's like an undeniable classic take
care
people argued whether or not it's a
classic and and so I I think take care
is a classic personally for me it's a
classic there's a lot of albums I
purchased I just don't think it's like a
like a undeniable
consensus classic album like you know
when you say doggy style get rich or die
trying like these are albums like nobody
will ever say anything different take
care it's close but like you said
there's a lot of people who say Drake
doesn't have a classic album
I think take care is a classic I just
don't think it's like
it's not a consensus like yo undeniable
nobody's gonna say [__] to you if you
say
you know aquemine from Outcast is a
classic like who's gonna say like you
know what I'm saying take care there's
some there's some you know some
there might be an argument I had this
argument with my manager the other day
and I was like go back and play the
album because I think a lot of people
don't realize that all those records
were on that same album A lot of times
because Drake had a he Drake has had a
crazy run he's still in his run right
but at that time he was just literally
like he owned the radio he owned all the
spaces put Kendrick on there yeah bro
like yeah Kendrick had his own record on
there right so
um when you go back and listen like how
many hit records he had on there that
weren't like even for a radio that's
just like yo this is just Drake you know
I think you'll you can say that one as a
classic I don't know what what whatever
crew levels on there right yeah yeah
Crew Love yeah yeah bro you know I don't
disagree with you I think it's a classic
but I just think that it's not like you
know
I think
I'm just waiting for for Drake to drop a
project
that like a pawn first listen you're
like oh my God
and I'm not saying that take care is not
that but I just mean like you can't say
[__] about good kid Man City yeah no
like if someone told you like nah that
ain't a classic you know like like you'd
be like you're you're like shut the [__]
up but a lot of people whose opinion
you would respect in hip-hop might not
say to take care as a client I just mean
it's a classic to me to you subjectively
we all have our own Classics you know
what I'm saying but I just don't think
Drake's got that one that like there's
no argument for I think the reason why I
take care is in a classic because it's
not a themed album I think the skits on
good kid Mad City is what makes it this
classic body of work the same thing with
uh tip of a butterfly or even damn it's
like it's a cohesive body of work to
where you cannot deny it and creatively
it was like a lot of
just risk-taking yeah I just think yeah
I I don't know man I love Drake
um Nothing Was the Same as my favorite
Drake album but I do think take care in
my book is classic yeah
um I used to Nothing Was the Same clouds
because that's more known
really yeah the clouds is like we see
those clouds on the album cover yeah oh
yeah that's on my Drake my favorite
Drake project it's a great album yeah
but it made sense you know exactly what
I'm talking about looking at those
clouds it makes sense so yeah so what uh
what's all right now you're independent
what's next for you this this project is
out it's been going crazy but what's
next for you so I got
two projects in the works I got
ignorance part two then I'm kind of iffy
I'm putting out because ignorance part
one was dedicated to my brother and I
don't want to step on his toes you know
uh and like kind of try to recreate some
energy when it was like really organic
and then I'm working on on my debut I
even know nobody's looking for it I'm
like literally just putting songs away
so you're like official album like the
official like more than seven tracks
I've never put out an EP that's more
than seven tracks I want to really have
something where like it's undeniable
from top to bottom so I'm sitting on 50
60 records like every artist you know
sitting on a whole lot of records and
just waiting for the right time to put
it out because I what's the right time
though there is no right time but like
how do you determine that I hate when
people say that I'm waiting for the
right time to put something
I don't know it was the right to put out
Idols when I put it out because a lot of
people using the pandemic on why they're
not putting music I'm like you're
[__] tripping people are at home with
nothing to do they're gonna and they're
listening to music yeah
I just feel like my thing is I always
want to put out a body of work that is
cohesive every one of my body at Works
was themed every single one of them so I
don't want to just put out a body of
work just like oh this is music here you
can have it I might put out a single but
I don't want to just put out something
that is not like oh I understand what
you're trying to do here because I feel
like that's the biggest thing for me as
an artist like yo he's telling stories
but everything he does
and everybody at work meant something to
him
um you talked about
obviously the capital deal came came
into play and a lot of people are trying
to sign you
um
can you talk about like you said you
were eating dinner and someone called
you yeah so I was eating dinner well
Thanksgiving dinner Thanksgiving dinner
so this is like three years ago this is
two years two years ago 2018. yes I had
dropped this is when I had dropped a
minute at a time and top calls me and he
didn't he said oh I'm gonna hit you but
I didn't think he's gonna hit me on
Thanksgiving so I'm like who is this
he's like this top I'm like what like
you know what I'm saying it was top so
that that kind of like solidified what I
I was really really doing at that time
were you already did you already make
the decision to uh I was already signed
the capital at the time but I had
already fulfilled my deal but I still
need to give them another project
because I want to put the project out so
long story short took the meeting with
top he was [__] with what I was doing
but then I still had to fulfill the rest
of my duties to Capital and I you know I
love top dog like I think that's one of
those labels that represent artistic
context but you're doing for real like
yeah them dream field I don't know what
they finna do with uh PG Lang but that
might be a pocket but yeah I really love
what the guys over there at top dog is
doing and like you know like I said I
ended up staying at Capital you know
fulfilling the rest of my deal but yeah
I would love to work with top of like he
understands what I'm trying to say so
the video you shot that went viral um
it's there's been a lot of videos that
have been similar to that video since it
came out yeah yeah yeah I remember
specifically
when the baby put out his video what
song was it the baby they did it for the
rock star the rock star remix yeah yeah
when he did the black black lives Matter
Remix yeah and um
very similar almost to the T yeah
um
how did you feel when you saw that
I think now because I think the baby was
like the last person that's done it
right well yeah because there were some
other there were some other artists
similar yeah yeah
but uh long story short the baby didn't
I I kind of felt like yo
I'm here to inspire I can't be mad when
I Inspire somebody you know and I may
not even have inspired the baby I may
have inspired his his director or his
team yes we were talking about that I
was like I'm not sure the baby like saw
that and was like let's do that it might
have been a subconscious effort on his
director whoever his videographer was
because it was it was like damn yeah but
then again I put out that video back in
2017 who's to say that his director had
that in his subconscious and didn't even
remember like how did exactly yeah you
know so like like I said like he was
telling the story and if if your
director is getting inspired to tell a
story something similar to what I did
you know pushing we pushing the same
message I was gonna say like did did you
um
any sort of communication with him or
his camp at all about it no I I had
tweeted I was like yo this looks very
familiar and I would say that tweet kind
of went up got a bunch of like replies
and uh retweets and [__] like that so
that was it but I didn't I didn't reach
out to nobody it ain't
it's not my business you know I'm saying
I got I got my bag I got my deal off
that video so it's like if you want to
eat too go ahead you know I'm still
eating off that song so it's like yeah
when you when your videos are so like uh
conceptually so dope like
is it it's like is it hard to like out
like like
when you shoot videos like that
that are so
conceptually at a high level like
can it be frustrating to just shoot a
regular video or just like every vid
like I feel like you you like you gotta
I don't know outdo yourself but like
that [__] you know you got some crazy
visuals bro I think I write I write
songs visually so I see the video first
video as I'm writing like while you're
writing literally like when I just was
doing a freestyle I had my eyes closed I
literally literally visually see what
I'm saying so a lot of times it's not
hard to come up with these conceptual
videos it's hard to execute them
sometimes because sometimes the idea is
so Grand and now being independent you
ain't got Capital that's going to spend
50 000 on the video you know like you
got to come out of pocket so yeah I
literally visually write every song
every video I don't know if a lot of
people know but like like I I directed
and wrote those treatments for all those
well you said you shot the uh that video
yourself right yeah yeah yeah literally
that shit's crazy on a on a I just put
the camera on the floor that was
Kool-Aid and cornstarch yeah
bro I spent seven dollars on that video
and that video changed my life that's
[__] crazy artists out there don't
make no [__] excuses about what you
should be doing because you can make
this [__] happen uh they're cheap I want
I wanted to ask you obviously we're at
the end of the year what's your um who's
your like what's your favorite album of
the Year we're just talking about the
Grammy nominations but what's your
personal top album in 2020 top album
2020 is definitely no love lost by blast
that's fair that is that an EP that's I
don't know what that is but it's EP but
no no we were just talking about
blasting there yeah yeah yeah so was
about this and by the way the way he
shot the videos yeah crazy so the homie
City James directed that and he's fine
he's gonna type in with CD James and
look at his videos my God he's really
like he's vaping yeah man yeah so yeah
so yeah if all right so if we want to
say blast album is not an album so let's
call that an epic I already call that an
EP he's got the deluxe coming out which
we'll kind of fill it out to be held
down because I I'm drawing a blank here
let me see who while you're while you're
looking that up let's go through the
best hip-hop album nominees and who you
think will win we got Alfredo from
Freddie Gibbs and Alchemist uh we got
Royce's album D smoke black habits
NASA's King disease and
Jay Electronica
I think either uh Freddie or Naz is
gonna win they might give it Nas might
be the clear winner you know what's
funny is I said the same thing I'm like
a Freddy should win but they might just
give it to NAS because Nas never had a
Grammy out of respect for the culture so
I would say one of the biggest albums in
Hip we sing in hip-hop no no your
favorite like album of the year
I would say I because I don't really be
listening I was like that but if I'm
saying I'm down let's say I would say uh
pop smoke they shoot at the stars that
was a great that was a great album for
me it's a great album that I listen to
because I've been listening to like a
lot of eps and [__] like that like you
do you [__] with uh Kion bill you know
yeah of course it's his little thing was
uh after hours yeah he's dope he's dope
that was a great he's got to put his
shirt on though yeah that guy never did
[__]
put a shirt on my guy but uh yeah so
yeah I think those those projects really
are something that I listen to a lot
like on repeat especially like I was
saying like that blast project I'm glad
you said his name because I I didn't
know if it was Zion or yeah because
because it's what the x is in his name
so yeah yeah I'm glad now I know how to
say his name I don't know if he's trying
to do like you know how blast got like
the X in his right maybe that's why he's
doing it like because the X kind of
looks like a k I don't know I don't know
I don't know why he did that I had to
ask him like yo because I went to high
school with him he went to uh we won the
same high school yeah his project is
dope though yeah so a lot of a look
there's like a lot of dope [__] coming
out of L.A right now yeah on the r b
side yeah bro L.A kind of kind of doing
their damn thing bro for real definitely
now I agree I think blast is uh
you know if we're talking about just
bodies of work ep's albums it's up there
man yeah and I didn't know I was looking
at the credits the other day bro he's
producing all that himself yeah I was he
was up here for the podcast and he's
like Russ he records himself mixes and
produces Masters and like he does
everything himself yeah it's crazy yeah
I I record mix and master all my stuff
but I don't produce the Beats like
that's he'd be making his own next level
like we start producing your [__] well
you know the Caitlyn record uh the the
the pull-up and get right with it he
produced that wow so that that he that's
his beat over that Kaelyn record yeah
that's crazy super crazy shout out to
blast man yeah bro you got music with
blast yeah we got a we got like a song
we hit that I don't know hit boy yeah he
produced it me him and hit it sounds
like a big move man I hope it's like a
big move for the city if hit clear that
[__]
he'd clear that [__] so that'd be some
dope [__] that'd be some dope [__]
that's the record we did like a year
maybe a year and a half ago yeah and
that's before you know glass was blast
yeah he had literally just put up off
the strength like yo bro I [__] with
your [__] let's work you know what I'm
saying I ain't even tapped in with him
I'm like bro fly young man do your thing
you know I don't want to be the guy that
like y'all remember this this record we
got you know I don't want to do that bro
fly spread your wings my guy because I'm
rooting for you for sure yeah that pop
smoke album though they did a great job
with it man I thought that uh you know
it's hard to pull off
an album when someone's not here anymore
especially kind of knowing that probably
a lot of those songs weren't finished
they did a masterful job yeah yeah yeah
I was wondering how they pulled off
certain things and and I don't know how
much how much 50 had his hands in it but
that was it was it was dope because he
had a couple great records on there oh
yeah solid body of work yeah so shout
out to pop smoke yo what's up man Pool
Lake Kev here shout out to the homies at
Odd Socks for sponsoring the bootleg cab
podcast and showing us love man and let
me tell you something we don't take
everyone's money that's not true
we'll take everyone's money but Donald
Trump's but with that being said we [__]
with Odd Socks all right
um I've been rocking Odd Socks for like
eight years now and um man Christmas
time coming up make sure you get you
some Odd Socks first of all let's talk
about these Basics right here
these joints are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet all right
no design no license but just crazy so
make sure you get some of those all
right then they got the Nickelodeon they
got the uh Scarface they got Tapatio
they got WWE how about Chef from South
Park you know what I'm saying whatever
you need shout out Stone Cold Steve
Austin by the way these are the socks
that I wear when I uh
drink PBR and
yell at my wife uh anyway
um shout out to Old Dirty Bastard too go
to oddsoxofficial.com right now all
right
now go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
keyword bootleg Kev and you will receive
20 off at checkout go do that so we
don't have any sort of so you're
thinking about dropping uh well you're
putting records aside for your album
yeah thinking about dropping a follow-up
EP yeah
next year early next year I'm yeah I'm
not gonna do it this year if I'm not if
I'm gonna be [__] we got three weeks
left yeah right so yeah uh so yeah
either uh most likely early next year
January February probably another EP and
then began working towards the album but
my manager was telling me like bro just
keep dropping EPS just keep dropping
little small bite-sized bodies of work
until people are begging for an album
and then just do it hey man run up that
catalog yeah bro that's what yeah bro I
just you know getting you know my first
independent Spotify check I'm like I'm
gonna run up this catalog just keep
going because yeah cause now now you got
the you got the listeners you got the
monthly listeners that are tapped in
they'll get that release radar you know
yeah it's kind of crazy that we're
talking out loud about this like it's
like something you got to think about
like okay I got people on Spotify
listening so I got to keep on feeding
them yeah so it hits their algorithm and
their algorithmic playlists their daily
mixes and all that [__] yeah man but
it's just the world we in man that's
yeah that's where we're at and that's
what I realized like you can't
especially as an independent artist you
can't wait too long you cannot wait too
long wait too long but you also can't
overdo it yeah you know so I'm like okay
cool I I don't know who said it like you
should kind of try to be on a three to
four month when you're independent if
you're doing EPS three to four a month
radius to where it's like drop some
weight a couple months drop them drop
something because if you keep smacking
people over the head every 30 days
they're gonna stop listening that's too
much unless you're doing singles yeah
but before projects definitely I don't
know if I'm like a single artist at this
point don't worry just like I like I
like bodies of work towards like oh I
see what you're trying to do not for
sure yeah yeah I mean I get it and doing
EP thing smart yeah I like I actually
like it that way I feel like giving
people a bite-sized amounts of content
is is the way to go I don't I get I see
an album with
19 songs on and get scared like that's
too much yeah man
it's too much for me it's a lot there's
no bro there's like three people in the
game that I would listen to their whole
album
well I mean especially if it's 19 songs
yeah I think dot can drop a album at
night he could drop a 40 song album and
I'm I'm in yeah yeah whatever Kendrick
wants to just whatever like I think dot
and cold do you think of Drake dropped
before you listen all of it I didn't
listen to all the Scorpion to answer
your question so yeah I mean I think I
might have listened to all of it but it
was like in pieces because it was like a
technically a double double album double
it was half already I like the r b side
to be honest a lot on on the Scorpion
but now like Drake
it took me a while like if Kendrick
drops a 40 song album I'm gonna smoke
some weed sit in my man cave
[__] and just zone out for two hours
two hours yeah and just be like yo
there's no way Kendrick's gonna drop a
40 song album and then not be a
masterpiece
Drake drop a 40 song album you're like
well you know that Chris Brown did that
was it last year Christmas 36 albums 36
it was something crazy some of the red
moon or something like that what's the
name man I was like yo
damn Breezy I I I [__] with you bro but
I'm I mean I got [__] to do I got a life
to live the songs I need to hear will
make their way to me yeah yeah bro I
feel like I feel like I was just talking
about that because that Chris Brown
record is one of my favorite records
right now though him and Young Thug Oh
yeah oh that I listed that record every
day like and that's a radio record I
don't typically go crazy yeah yeah go
crazy it's a beautiful song yeah yeah
bro so shout out to Chris Brown man yeah
man all right let me ask you something
is is Chris Brown
is he the most talented artist we've
ever seen I think he will be I think
unfortunately that incident with him
Ariana no no I'm not talking about that
I'm talking about is he the most
talented artist I'm saying yes I feel
like he would be God level had he not
done some stuff in his adolescence I
think he's God level you think he is I
don't think he gets the shiny he
deserves no but I'm not talking about
the shine or the record I'm talking
about Talent yeah God level yeah I've
been extremely critical of Chris Brown
and his personal decisions outside of
the Rihanna thing yeah
but Jesus Christ he's well he's out of
this world I'm like how do you still are
you making 50 song projects bro
he's an alien man and he can dance he
can paint a mural on a Ferrari yeah you
can sink a jump shot yeah
solid on the celebrity basketball game
yeah it was really mixing people bro he
could act yeah yeah I think about like I
said I hope we give that man his roses
bro because he's really a great yeah man
and I'm being very critical but I'm like
yo like I don't know if there's been
another more talented human being that
we've seen in the public eye besides
Chris Brown now you might argue that
there's people who's made better music
but but just pure talent Chris Brown is
Chris Brown makes phenomenal music who's
really making better music than Chris
Brown I mean you know I think if I mean
not anymore I was gonna say Kanye but
not anymore but yeah
Jesus Jesus king is it can turn I don't
know all this [__] that Na Na Na song
Kanye drop is the worst [__] Kanye
song he's ever released besides the
people who did he scoop [__] but that
was that was troll he was trolling and
that beat was fire on the scoop [__]
that b was crazy what I wanted to I
really would have loved to have heard
what Drake did on that because that was
Drake's beat yeah that's what Drake was
saying like Kanye gave it to him
especially on top of it but yeah I just
hope Kanye pulls his his head out the
ground and just starts getting back I
don't know man I don't know how if he
can be as a creative Artist as we would
want him to be while he's like a
hardcore Christian I think
I know uh one of The Producers that's
over there them joints and he's like
really out of this damn joints produce
they're not on us yeah so great beat but
yeah bro so I know that because I've
written records with him and he's
produced a couple records for me he's
Artistic integrity so I'm pretty sure if
he's rubbing shoulders with Kanye
I'm pretty sure the next project I have
faith in the snakes by the way I hope so
I just feel like people are just like
I'm just happy to be in the room with
Kanye let him do whatever [__] he
wants to do and we're just here for it
because he's yay and we grew up loving
him and yeah he's my favorite artist
ever yeah like number one I mean he's
not my favorite MC ever but like artist
wise I don't feel like anyone's ever
made better music in hip-hop than Kanye
West yeah Artistry yeah I don't I don't
think nobody
yeah I think if if
I think if Kendrick gives us something
completely different on his next project
this is what I always say to people
right so
everyone puts biggie in there
and I I put biggie in my top ten
biggies were my favorite rappers ever
but biggie is consistently putting
people's top five top three top two
whatever offer two albums two right two
Classics life after death ready to die
incredible bodies of work
undisputable Classic Albums um
but Kendrick
he's dropped I mean I can can consider
section 88 classic but if we let's
discard section 80 because some people
it wasn't a mixtape you couldn't
download it for free you had to buy it
on iTunes but
if you just take his three albums that
came out through Interscope Untitled
aside
like you got to put Kendrick he's like
four or five all the time in my book man
yeah like I don't see how you could like
like when you drop music that's on that
level three times in a row four times in
a row to me you know because I think
section 80 is amazing yeah like bro what
are we talking about I think it's just
because he's young and he's here right
now that's what it is that's what it is
oh maybe it's recency bias like no
Kendrick is [__] that dude bro yeah
and nobody wants to smoke with kdot who
would who would who would do that this
man has been throwing subliminal shots
at Drake and bro who wants smoke with
Kendrick
nobody will say his name because they
will get destroyed yeah like the control
verse was such a moment man shout out to
Kendrick man yeah top five all time
yeah I think I think people want to deny
that because like I said because he's
here a lot of times people you know you
you pass away and you just become this
super Idol Lord forbid if if Kendrick
passed away yeah it's great everyone
would be like yo he's top three all the
time you know and it's whack that that
that's the type of [__] that has to
happen yeah I think Kendrick is on
another level because and I think that's
the difference between Cole and Kendrick
is Kendrick knows how to make hit
records and keep them punches like damn
was all hit records bro and they're all
conscious records not you can't really
me being a conscious artist I know the
difficulty of having some [__] that
knocked but it's like I'm really telling
you something you know that's that's
really difficult you know so I think if
if we want to have that conversation the
top five people man I don't know who
like yeah I don't know if you can find
four other like whoa yeah I feel like
there's like you know probably a six or
seven rapper range that you could kind
of rearrange into like who's the top
five ever but like I feel like
Hendrick's in that conversation how
close I want to ask you a question
because I always ask people this
question and nobody can ever answer it
or let's just say Kendrick Cole and
Drake are at the top of the game who's
in that space to even be close to it
that's not bottom level it's like a long
three-mile Gap in between now who is
even a mouth up in that Gap you know
what's interesting is
I don't think we put Kanye in that
conversation because I don't think
people
um
I think I think Kanye has to be the
fourth guy there just consistency over
the last 12 15 years whatever but I also
don't think Kanye like lyrically
is on that level um
but yeah I don't know man I the first
name that comes to mind and I would be
like a Big Sean maybe or like
yeah but but it's a far it's far if
Kendrick Cole and Drake are tens what
would Big Sean be a six no disrespect
right right well that's what I'm saying
like seven eight and nine that you know
it's it would have to yeah like I'm just
trying to think so I'm thinking Big Sean
is is kind of that next tier
and then like
yeah I don't know man
who else is
not just just overall greatness that's
that's right now that's relevant right
now of course you can throw Dre I mean
not Dre J in there Jay-Z in there but
he's already he's already passed the
generation yeah we're talking about
right now I'm thinking right now and and
I think
you would you would have to put Kanye in
that top tier but like I don't think
relevance as an artist at the moment is
not what we're looking at yay for at the
moment I think we're looking at him for
things he's done already yeah so I would
just say that those are the three
and I'm not sure
where
you know if we're talking like impact
Commercial Success Artistic integrity
like yeah those those are the three and
and and anything below that is very far
away very very very very it's a gigantic
Gap
yeah I mean there's Independent Artists
that are super like I think you know I
think Freddie Gibbs has had a great run
recently you know I think um
you can look at
yeah but like we're talking Cole
Kendrick Drake you're 10 years old I
mean good command city was 2012. yeah
born Center was 2012 I think yeah it was
it was it was 2013 it came out the same
day as Jesus yeah and take take care was
what 2011. 2012. yeah yeah you're right
so those are the three I don't know who
else you would say man there's people
who had their pockets and their runs but
like not a decade bro yeah a decade of
consistently being the [__]
guys yeah turning on the radio and it's
like especially Drake what Drake doesn't
play fair
what do you say don't play just like
dude he's so like
Drake's
no one's ever been able to make
songs that are com like like he's the
biggest hit maker ever like it's just
not fair like Drake can literally do
anything and it's just it's it's number
one or it's it's it's like it's just
really not fair I think that we've never
seen anything like that ever in hip-hop
like what Drake's doing we've never seen
you could say well Wayne had a couple
year run where he was like
what Drake's doing nobody's ever done
you know what's crazy though if I tell
you name your top five rappers people
don't even put Drake in there I don't
I'm not a big drinker why though because
why don't we respect that man my uh my
manager told me he was like man those
those references man kind of killed him
for me man when I heard the running
through this six I was like oh wow
people you're not gonna get in that
discussion but I don't know but and the
thing is is for me that's why he can't
be in the in that discussion but he
could be in the biggest artist of all
time discussion he could be in the
biggest hip like I don't put Kanye in
the greatest MC discussion yeah give
but he's one of the biggest artists but
but yeah because I know Kanye openly has
people write him for him yeah you know
like uh rhymefest wrote Jesus Walks I
didn't know that yeah Ryan Fest wrote
that song wow so you know that doesn't
take away from Drake like I told you
Kanye is my favorite artist but I can't
put him in that conversation just like I
can't put Drake in that conversation but
Drake don't play fear man you think
Drake got somebody writing his bars I
don't know I think I mean you go listen
to that Google he wrapped re-wrapped all
them Clinton Miller bars those reverses
but that's not even our favorite Drake
project what do you think he got another
secret person you know a lot of people
like that uh if you're reading this yeah
people really like that project yeah
because that was like him that was like
his rapid ass rapping project and the
fact that that was his rapping ass
rapping project and there was what two
references I believe there was just not
at least three three yeah so that's why
I'm like
I don't care because he makes enjoyable
music and he also delivers them because
if you listen to the Clinton Miller
versions of those songs they sound like
ass and then Drake gets on them and
you're like oh [__] yeah Drake don't
play fair man it's unfair no one's ever
done what he's he's doing
I'm not sure anyone will ever do what
he's doing yeah
it's like Drake the weekend
Bruno Mars
yeah like like when we're just talking
about Commercial Success who the [__] is
touching Drake bro he could do another
10 years like with his eyes closed yeah
bro it's it's ridiculous he could do
yeah bro and I'm a critical Drake fan
like I'm I I think that there's a lot of
things he hasn't done that I would like
to see him do I would like to see him
make a concept project all right so look
this is what I'm about to say earlier
so I was on uh you tapped it on
clubhouse man I was on there man I got
it bro but I just like I don't got time
for that yeah that should take your time
but it's good like if you're driving or
some [__] but like so long story short I
was having a conversation and they were
saying that Drake isn't isn't one of the
best Lyricist ever right and I was
saying
if we like to Be Wild by like super
duper triple entendras and all the other
stuff right but if you can say something
so simple that a baby can understand it
a teenager can understand it and a
grandmother can understand it does that
make not make you one of the best
lyricses because it's so easily easy to
uh digest sometimes Kendrick will say
some [__] that if you're not a rap head
you have no idea what he's talking about
same thing with Colt but if Drake can
simplify so much to what every single
person can understand it but it's still
the dopest line ever does that not make
him one of the greatest lyricists ever I
think
if he's writing those bars if he's
writing them then yeah I think Drake is
an elite MC yeah yeah I just don't know
what he's what is he riding what is he
not I don't know so the question that I
don't know would you be her would you be
would you heard let's say something came
on like Cole wasn't random [__] would
you be hurt of course of course I'd be
like what yeah like if someone told me
Kendrick didn't write his [__] or there
was I would I would be heartbroken
that's what that's what head asked me
like yo what if he found out Pock and
Biggie had ghost writers how would you
feel about yourself I'm like damn I
don't know what I'll do I mean
I think that there's a lot of our our I
think that there's some substantial
situational evidence that Wayne has had
some help with some of his bars I I
think when this is my own bias but I
think when Drake first came out
I think Drake was helping Wayne with
some bars because there was very similar
when Drake had really the kid yeah we
know that but that was a long time ago
man well you know that though because
you remember there was such a jump yeah
because like Wayne was like block his
high five 500 Degrees and then all of a
sudden just back he was rapping rapping
and he was always solid yeah like I
always thought he was the best dude in
the hot boys as far as like who I like
to hear rap but you know obviously
juvenile probably made the best music in
that era but
there was a big jump man his pen game he
took a [__] leap on Carter one and
those Squad up mixtapes and all that
[__] so yeah I don't know I also know
people have been in the studio with
Wayne and they're like he's an alien he
goes in and it's all off the top of his
head and it's you know
I'm not
I'm a little Wayne fan but I'm very you
know critical well you know people
people really put Wayne in like if you
put Wayne in your top five I just can't
take you serious really I just can't do
it man my God I can't my God I don't
know if Wayne would be top five but if
he definitely in the top seven come on
now I can't do it man Wayne also had
like a eight year run so well he didn't
have a year run what was it like two
thousand no no no think about six wait
wait so really think about it think
about his run right
so I believe Carter one was 0-5 I was
still in high school I was working the
Best Buy when Carter one came out oh
405. I think it was o5
I know Carter 2 was 07 or 08 right and
then no 08 was Carter three so Carter
three came out in 08 okay I know that
for sure okay because that was the first
year I ever got arrested
um
o4 was Carter one yeah so that was my
junior year in high school then when was
Carter two
was that 06
oh seven five oh five oh five wow okay
this is my freshman year well so think
about this right yeah
Carter one and Carter two Carter two is
my favorite Wayne album yeah but Carter
winning Carter two Wayne wasn't um
the biggest [__] guy like he wasn't
like the guy yet those were albums where
people were like oh [__] then Carter two
came out he started calling himself the
best rapper alive right he had a song on
there exactly and even then like if you
think about Carter 2
like what was the hit record like the
undeniable hit record it wasn't go DJ
wasn't like a super smash and was that
it was go DJ go DJ Carter one yeah
Carter one yeah so go DJ was Carter one
that record was dope and it got radio
play
but like his commercial
foot like I think after Carter two he
started that feature running that
drought the drought series and all that
[__] dedication dedication [__] and then
Carter three was like the cherry on top
bro and during that whole run he was
just on everybody's [__] so I would
argue to say
that Wayne's run as the guy probably
started in like 07 Carter three dropped
that was the peak
and then by like 2010 it was Drake's
world yeah so you say he had a
three-year run as the guy bro as the guy
I don't know maybe because I'm a rapper
rapper bro when he was putting out the
dedication one that's what 2006. like
come on now you know what's crazy I was
like that was a run all my favorite all
my favorite Wayne [__] is [__] that
isn't even on like it's all it's on that
piff yeah about that yeah
but I just don't like no no like if
you're counting like Carter one all the
way till I just think that after Carter
three he dropped No Ceilings which to me
was the last great lyrical Lil Wayne
yeah because I wasn't a fan of Carter 4.
it had some hits on it yeah by the way
[__] in the comments hate me
because I just had Jay Mills up here and
I was [__] on the Carter four was
not a fan of the Carter four yeah huge
drop off to me yeah major right yeah and
then he did I'm Not a Human Being
revolver yeah he just had a lot of stuff
that just wasn't he went to the Rock
world and when he just wasn't like the
level of like when even the tapes he
dropped after that were just kind of
whatever it was like like No Ceilings
three just came out and it's like I
haven't even heard it yet I mean it's
cool there's some [__] on there yeah but
all right let's just say this so then
the Trump endorsement is the guy yeah
that was wow well you know why he did it
he did it to get the pardon for these
fed federal charges um you got you got
to know that that's coming uh because
he's got those gun charges that they
just brought up on him he might go to
prison I didn't know that when I saw
that I was like oh the Trump thing makes
sense Trump's gonna pardon Little Wayne
I'll put I'll put a thousand dollars
like Trump has to Pardon Little Wayne
there's no way Lil Wayne took a picture
with his ass we're in that goofy ass
sweater and Trump don't give him a
[__] party how many parties do the
president get as many as he wants it's
unlimited God damn yeah he gonna party
but look I'm gonna say this you saying
that and I'm not mad at him if he gets
the part if he gets the pardon it's all
good I get it bro you want to do 15
years in prison or go take a picture
with the [__] you know biggest [__]
sucker in the world I mean look
I get it to each their own but look this
is what I'm about to say for you to say
that Wayne run may not have been that
long but when it comes to influence in
today's world Wayne is the biggest come
on so why is he not in what are we just
basing up if he he's one of the greatest
lyricists we've ever heard some of his
punch lines is out of this world right
no no I mean I don't know if he's one of
the greatest lyrics oh my God you just
don't like this top 20 Lyricist oh
top 20 like would you put as a Lyricist
you say The Lyricist yes but he's not a
Storyteller when he's not gonna give you
a story but if we're talking about
saying lyrics sing dope [__] then there
I mean we don't want to dive in that
hole because I'll start the name of
names that you'll get mad about yeah no
so race to five nine is a better
Lyricist than Lil Wayne nah bro so what
how this this Freddy gives a better
Lyricist Lil Wayne
Taylor Mike's a better Lyricist Lil
Wayne
no you said Lyricist You Said Lupe
Fiasco wait wait wait lupees
one of the greatest lyricists ever but
he just don't get the the no but like
Lil Wayne is not even like sniffing that
level of lyricism so do you think do you
think Drake is a better Lyricist of
those than your name
because Wayne do you think when it comes
to rapping and punch lines yeah triple
entendras who's really touching him
other than Jay when it comes to Royce to
five nine yeah Lupe Fiasco yeah Killer
Mike uh
uh I mean but they're not on that Eminem
Eminem yeah he's on geminine is the man
of word Andre three thousand Andre three
thousand I mean I could keep going yeah
but I don't I'm not I've never tapped
into Royce I've never tapped into Killer
Mike Jay Electronica never typed into
jail electronic
Jay Electronica cowra come on
at all projects because I heard that
project I skimmed through it well that
project did not deserve enough I don't
disagree with you listen I I don't I
don't disrespect to them I don't know
maybe watch that man on that record I
don't I don't know listen I don't know
Jay electronic I have no dog in the jail
electronical fight
he should not have got nominated yeah
bro there's a there's a some others that
probably shouldn't have got nominated
but you know some homies of mine that
got nominated I'm happy for yeah what
album do you feel like should have got
on there I feel like Roddy rich and
little baby little baby bro Lil Baby has
had one of the greatest years Roddy rich
and little baby yeah oh yeah so I forgot
about but I Roddy's album came out in
December yeah
a little baby is the best album of this
year then I like little by baby I don't
album better than probably you know
what's crazy about a little baby is uh
if you're like a hardcore hip-hop head
you can still listen to his album and
it's like this [__] is fire bro he's
really talking about some [__] yeah
little baby shark is crazy I'm a huge
fan of I didn't know bro was that young
he's like 25 years old I think he's
younger than that oh I know 25. yeah
they just did the 30 on the 30 25 I
think he's 25 yeah they just did the
four is 30 on the 30. no listen I think
Wayne is dope I just
26. he's 26. wow I thought he was
younger than that you know I thought he
was like 22 or something oh oh today's
what's his birthday happy birthday
little baby yo so yeah man Wayne is fire
but I just think we put so much
he influences different influence
there's I mean okay where do you put
Tupac in your top as far as influence
he's he's like number one or number one
yeah because I'm from the West no no but
like overall Tupac influence everybody
everybody like Tupac is probably like
he's the most influential rapper I think
ever yeah it's like him yay
Hove Wayne I feel like
where hip-hop is and low-key future
where hip-hop is
if you got to give Drake a lot of credit
as far as influence like see I think
nobody was singing Drake was influenced
by 808s and heartbreaks but he was he
was he didn't say he will yeah yeah he
did but as far as making a whole career
out of rapping and singing no rappers
like hip-hop is now typically art it's
like basically it's all melodic it's all
melodic and R B yeah for sure Drake's up
there too
nobody was really doing that that's how
50 ended Ja Rule's career like bro you
seeing it on records that's what we're
doing
yeah I think it's Pock I think Wayne is
up there in influence
pot storytelling I want to visualize
your lyrics
I don't feel like Pac was gonna give you
like crazy crazy bar he's gonna make you
feel it emotionally I think Tupac
I would listen to Tupac 10 times out of
ten Over Lil Wayne
now do I think Lil Wayne is probably
technically a better Lyricist like if
we're talking about yeah probably but
but Tupac like you said earlier about
Drake Tupac could say some [__] so
simple and it just like hits you yeah
and that's a [__] talent in itself
it's the emotion in Tupac's voice
whatever that medicine yeah
yeah but I well we ain't talk about we
said Tupac and Wayne
but uh hold on I gotta send we got Pete
Rock calling in on Zoom hold on we're
talking about something 12 45 okay we
got 20 minutes
give me a sec
sorry guys mid podcast text wrapping up
um so yeah shout out to Wayne I'm a
Wayne fan I enjoy the Wayne I I like I
enjoy the Wayne I enjoy but man man
these young kids bro I have some guy in
here tell me that bro there's this kid
named Vino this rapper who who I'm
working with he's 23. and with a
straight face he told me no one's had a
better 10 years in hip-hop history than
Lil Wayne from 98 to 08 and I said from
like what did you just say I wanted to
smack him and kick him out Jay-Z yeah
you wouldn't think about Jay-Z bro or
DMX or 50 or like during that span like
what anyway I don't think anyone's ever
had a bigger two or three you're one
than 50. yeah no 50 was the biggest
[__] on the planet it's 50 I
think the two biggest rappers ever at
their peak of snooping 50.
like doggy style Snoop he's on the cover
of [__] Rolling Stones Peak bro he
was bro no I'm talking about I'm talking
bro nah bro God level it was a point
where Wayne anything that Wayne touched
bro I think Wayne's in 0708 I think
you'll get Wayne like he's in that top
five
run with his Peak how high he got bro
you know Wayne's up there that his
period of time where he was like the
biggest bro what was the last time I
know we in a different era now but Wayne
didn't do like 1.3 million in a week
when he dropped Carter three like come
on now that's a run bro
Eminem to you but yeah
yeah
I don't think I I think I don't know I
think Marshall Mathers LP didn't age too
well to be honest
no no yeah but I just think Peak is
snooping it's it's 50. yeah what if 50
sounds first week no I don't remember
but that [__] but I'm pretty sure you
ever remember somebody coming out of the
debut album with more anticipation of
50. yeah that [__] was crazy I wonder
how the [__] did it happen like that
because it wasn't like he was doing a
crazy feature run it wasn't like in the
club was that [__] it was a
it was it was like I can't remember a
bigger song than in the but I remember
having that [__] on a k slay mixtape on
my disc man in high school and me and my
friends would just listen to in the club
with all the drops and shout outs over
and over I feel like I'm gonna say this
and this might be crazy bro I feel like
as big as the box was if we were in a
selling record time I feel like it would
have did those type of numbers bro
definitely the box was one of the
craziest records I've heard I agree
wholeheartedly I'm literally in my car
bro right away when I was I was in
Hawaii listening to the album and they
were like yo yo we should be playing uh
I forget which record that they wanted
to play at the station
because it had a feature on it it had uh
uh you talking about the one with uh
the dude from the kid from New York
anybody on it that record there was a
record on there they were like no no
we're gonna go with this one because
it's got the big feature until the label
picks it I'm like bro the box is the box
it's like track two there's a track two
right oh my God I heard that I was like
oh my God I showed it to everybody I
think Roddy rich and post Malone have
the best Melodies in the history of
music I hate to say that because people
are gonna hate kill me in the comments
but bro the way Roddy Rich can skate in
a verse melodically democracy hits on
his Melodies it's [__] crazy at least
in the in the last like 10 years I don't
know about the history of you there's
Michael Jackson there's Quincy Jones
there's [__] you know Lionel Richie
but God I bet Drake hit some crazy
Pockets no no Drake but I just think
Drake and post like they're like Melody
game is so unfair yeah I've been like
it's impossible for Roddy Rich to not
make a song that is easy to listen to
yeah like I've never heard of Roddy
record that I'm like
man turn that [__] off yeah it's like
all his record like post Malone's the
same way like even if you're not a post
Malone fan all his music he's got to get
bro he's his flowers he's out of here
bro it's crazy he's one of those artists
that literally just makes hits after
hits that's all he does and then Roddy's
gonna be the same way yeah I'm excited
to see what Roddy does next because bro
I got feelings coming soon we'll see
been a year since I'm dropped yeah it
came out last December yeah I was in
Hawaii it was just it came out the same
the same week the juice World died wow
yeah it was crazy I remember I was in
Hawaii for the first time riding around
convertible listening to Roddy's album
found out juice World died I was like
[__] yeah shout out to uh to to uh Roddy
rich though but yo man your project
Idols is out yep um go follow uh we
actually got a freestyle dropping with
him too that'll come out a few days
after this comes out so being on the
lookout for that and uh be able to look
out for a lot of stuff with you yeah you
can stay independent for a while yeah
man I'm good on bread so there you go
yeah that's bro
yeah I'm good on bread so I don't need
to do no crazy deal like I said it's
it's labels that I would want to work
with drop some [__] merch man yeah
you don't talk you gotta run that merch
up bud yeah I'm gonna run some [__] up
katori Walker if you haven't heard his
[__] go tap in tap in boom